ich wurde für noch 26 geschätzte die
königin von england auf 22 hallo mein
name ist luca und ich habe ein alter und
das hat jeder mensch
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht meine
damen und herren wir spielen heute
einfach mal die holt duo lag bei dieser
app geht es darum dass wir ein foto
auswählen können was ich mir vorher auf
dem handy abgespeichert habe und dann
sagt uns diese app wie alt die person
ist die auf diesem foto dargestellt wird
hier sehen übrigens oben wieder werbe
video eingeblendet weil das ganze in
kooperation mit google play entstanden
ist also ich hab mir wieder ein spiel
aus dem google places runtergeladen und
werde das jetzt mit euch zusammen
spielen also wir fangen an
hier klicken erstmal auf take me to
select und jetzt können wir entweder ein
foto aufnehmen oder 1 aus der galerie
auswählen ich würde sagen test deshalb
nehmen wir erst mal ganz kurz zu foto
von mir auf also hier nämlich gerade den
ton auf jetzt wünschen wir das ganze mal
da befinde ich mich gerade war die
kamera ist echt ein bisschen zum schaf
ein paar sekunden später
wundervoll
klasse fotos geworden jetzt kriegen wir
einfach mal hier und auf den haken
können das ganze bild jetzt hier noch
mal heben drehen machen dass man hier so
ein bisschen so ein bisschen größer so
genau dass hier bin jetzt ich klicken
mal auf
ja
das ist meine nase ist ein dummkopf
ich habe jetzt ein neues foto
aufgenommen klicke einfach mal auf den
haken drehe das ganze jetzt einfach mal
packt das jetzt mal hier direkt hinblick
auf save
er schätzt mich fünf jahre älter als ich
wirklich bin das sieht man natürlich
gern
jetzt kommen wir unten auf schergen oder
save drücken ich würde sagen wir kriegen
einfach offen ob ich immer noch gleich
alt bin und wir sehen ich bin immer noch
wir gehen jetzt allerdings einfach mal
zurück und klicken wieder take me to
select vom gallery und jetzt sehen wir
hier schon bei den downloads
ja
da seht ihr schon alle bilder die ich
heute testen wollen meine damen und
herren wir sagen wir fangen an mit einer
person die ich die tage besucht habe
weil sich zu hause ein mega mega netter
kerl ab mit ihm zusammen im blog eine
musik challenge aufgenommen es ist felix
jenen er sieht so bubi mäßig da aus wir
klicken einfach mal auf save und jetzt
sagt uns die app wie alt
ja ich bin 21 werde auf 26 geschätzt
felix ist 23 auf 22 geschätzt was ist
das ist komplett in ordnung
felix an der stelle schöne grüße an dich
du siehst auf jeden fall jünger aus als
du wirklich bist ein zweites bild habe
ich eine person gewählt die ich bei der
einschaltquote getroffen habe er hat
keinen preis gewonnen tatsächlich obwohl
ich mir das gewünscht hätte weil ich
auch einige frühere lieder von ihm sehr
sehr gefeiert habe nach bevor dieser
ganze hype jetzt in cham und zwar pause
ab meine damen und herren als vision das
ganze ein bisschen zurecht hier das
können wir noch so ein bisschen hier
anpassen genau klicken wenn man auf save
und jetzt schauen wir mal da ist 30 wenn
ich jetzt noch wüsste wie alt ein echtes
fauser alter gehen wir einfach mal bei
google einer sehen wir noch
das ist das ist genau das ist browser
1989 in saarbrücken bürgerlich julian
otto julia otto 1989 das self das heißt
er ist 28
wenn wir noch mal eingehen 30 ok wird
ein bisschen älter geschätzt aber jetzt
auch nicht krass alter meine damen und
herren als nächste person habe ich
wirklich eine person gewählt da muss ich
wirklich sagen finde ich den content auf
youtube zumindest komplett beschissen er
jetzt letztes neues merchandise
rausgebracht
das kam am 11 12 die shop adresse ist
auch so total bescheuert der user hat
doch vor ein paar tagen ein buch
herausgebracht das er zusammen mit
seiner mutter über sein leben
geschrieben hat so voll viele private
informationen drin sind finde ich ja
völlig bescheuert ja nie machen also
willkommen auf dem punkt ist luca kong
crafter sonst alltag menschen abstoßend
machen dass wir noch ein bisschen größer
ein bisschen hin und her klicksafe mal
schauen wie alt ich jetzt geschätzte 23
wohin war ich noch 26 weiß jedoch
wirklich am foto lag also wir gehen
jetzt mal zurück haben möchte ich hier
nochmal auf die kamera es wird schon mal
um das heißt wenn ich jetzt mal
irgendwie so ein bisschen wie kann ich
ein bisschen süß gucken nur wenige
minuten später
ich sehe einfach immer beschissen aus
noch etwas länger als nur wenige minuten
später
man die machen die denn auf instagram
alle ich kann das nicht so gut
ich klicke auf save mal schauen
wahrscheinlich 522
er schätzt wirklich auf 22 bis 21 als
nächstes bild habe ich hier wirklich
eine person ausgewählt die in jedem
leben noch überhaupt nichts erreicht hat
wie in elisabeth dietz weiter meine
damen und herren königin von england ich
wurde für ein auf 26 geschätzte die
königin von england auf 22 ist komplett
legitim macht natürlich sinn dass ich
als 21-jähriger auf 26 beziehungsweise
22 geschätzt werde und dann kommt die
queen an die königin von england wird
auf 22 geschätzt wie ich auf jeden fall
genauso ob jetzt habe ich tatsächlich
mal wieder ein youtuber ausgewählt wo
wir mal schauen wollen wir alle diese
personen geschätzt wird es ist ein
mädchen mit der ich zusammen unter
anderem die moral in war auf einigen
aftershow parties hatten wir spaß mit
das hört sich falsch an da gebe ich
meine damen und herren meine absolute
lieblingsstadt jubeln so wie jeder jeder
ist mein lieblings youtuber hier klicken
einfach mal auf save und schauen mal wie
alter geschätzt wird
da wird einfach kein gesicht gefunden
da geh ich würde mir da echt mal
gedanken machen wurde ein gesicht ist
justin bieber schauen wir mal als
nächstes m ich glaube dass 22 auf 28
geschätzt ich meine hat sich natürlich
auch ordentlichen bart wachsen lassen
ein weiterer künstler der musikszene
rennen meine damen und herren er hat
große erfolge feiern können und auch bei
der einzelne kunde bei der ich war ein
preis abgesahnt
wir kriegen einfach mal auf save schauen
wie alten geschätzt wird auf 19
er ist älter als 19 ich sehe schon
wieder die kommentare kommen luca toni
wieder nur irgendwelche leute aus der
musikszene oder aus der jugend oder
irgendwelche youtube oder so noch mal
leute die wirklich was die man anderen
branchen- bekannten sind daten war jetzt
vorhin die queen der lippe bist die auf
22 geschätzt wurde als nächstes würde
ich sagen nehmen wir da einfach mal
gerhard schröder hier meine damen und
herren blicken einfach mal auf save guck
mal wie aldi angela merkels 19 ja klar
ich werde auf 26 geschätzt ich glaube
diese apple ist einfach nur ein
zufallsgenerator was das alter angeht
logan paul der derzeit am stärksten
wachsende
youtube kanal wie kriegt man auf save
schauen wir also das 21
ich glaube der ist sogar 21 oder 22 oder
irgendwie so bleiben anlagen paul drin
hat darf natürlich auch sein bruder jake
paul nicht fehlen meine damen und herren
also wir gehen ja da noch mal nur ein
bisschen näher dran her da kann man auch
mal ein bisschen das bild ein bisschen
grün genau
genau so will ich sein gesicht sehen
so genau passen was man hier noch so ein
bisschen an klickt man auf safeway
paulus auf jeden fall eigentlich jünger
als slogan hier wird er genauso alt
geschätzt wie ich max krankhafter meine
damen und herren guter freund von mehr
guck dir sehr ernst das war glaube ich
im video was er namens adam aufgenommen
hat warum er keine videos mit seiner
freundin hochlädt oder irgendwas da
hatte ich das jetzt raus genommen das
ist wirklich eines der einzigen bilder
wo die qualität stimmt und er wirklich
in die kamera guckt also ich klicke
einfach mal auf save mal schauen wie alt
max ist er ist 28 und die bücher im
hintergrund sind 27 krass
er wird noch älter geschätzt als ich und
ich bin eigentlich ein jahr älter als
max aber freunde wenn wir hier wirklich
schon die elite von youtube wirklich die
bildungsfernen youtuber miteinbeziehen
darf natürlich auch gewinn zeit nicht
viel meine damen und herren also hier
ein tolles bild auf seinem blog wir
klicken einfach mal auf save und wir
sehen wie wird auf 26 geschätzt
irgendwie ist jeder 26 oder 28 revier
sind gleich alt
ne
ich glaube sogar wirklich 26 oder 25
oder irgendwie so wo wir gerade von
bildung auf youtube gesprochen haben
meine damen und händler darf natürlich
auch nicht meine absolute lieblingsstadt
über rinnen babys beauty fellas ja die
wifi fellas können babys beauty palace
darf nicht fehlen meine damen und herren
euer katzenohren osterhasen wie hat sich
das bild hier genannt das heißt wir
schauen einfach mal wie alt sie sich
denken sie ist so 23 oder irgendwie 73
mal gelesen safe und 719 klar wie wir
eigentlich älter als ich aber hier
sieben jahre yoga oder was es ist aber
echt so lustig einfach zuschauen was
diese app denkt die alte leute sind also
freunde wenn ihr bock auf mehr mobile
gaming habt findet jetzt hier oben eine
umfrage eingeblendet und da könnt ihr
einfach mal sagen habt ihr bock auf mehr
solcher sachen habt also wenn ich solche
sachen einfach mobil aufnehmen oder wenn
er sagt luca das ist echt nicht so cool
dass die wir was anderes suchen klicken
einfach auf nein aber also mich wird
eure meinung sehr interessieren aber
hier noch ein youtuber denen ja
das
das sagt alles ein youtuber den ich
leider einmal kennenlernen musste und
leider letzten videos mit drehen musste
sascha ist unsympathisch as [ __ ] ich
weiß nicht wie alt sascha ist ich
schätze ihn mal irgendwie so auch auf 24
oder 3 und 23 24 klickt einfach mal auf
save mal schauen wie alter geschätzt
wird er wird hier auf
ich glaube
dann auf 17 geschätzt ich fühle mich
mittlerweile echt beleidigt weil ich
neben browser auf älteste geschätzt
wurde
als letztes bild habe ich wirklich eine
person ausgewählt die in meinen augen
eines der hübschesten mädchen der welt
ist wenn sie nicht der zeit ich glaube
wieder mit justin bieber zusammen wer
würde ich direkt nach raleigh fliegen
und versuchen sie kennenzulernen selena
gomez
meine damen da kann man ruhig mal nach
lautern hat zu kämpfen mit einer sehr
krassen krankheit setzt sich viel für
alle menschen ein ist ein unfassbarer
hübscher mensch und fast mal sympathisch
auch in interviews also dass selena
bitte heirate mich wir schauen mal wie
ein zu denen geschätzt wird ich glaube
sie jetzt du 22 oder 28
ja
sie ist definitiv 28 das war's jetzt vom
video meine damen und herren wenn es
euch gefallen hat das gerne wahr einen
like da wie gesagt schon oben die ganze
zeit werbevideo weil das ganze video
hier in kooperation mit google playern
standes also in kooperation mit dem
google places tor und sonst meine damen
und herren kommen wir jetzt zu dem teil
des videos wo ich wirklich sagen muss wo
das ist das outro das was ihr vom video
das war's jetzt ihr vom video hier
können jetzt hier mal den kanal
abonnieren oder hier unten meinen job
ausschenken hier findet ihr zwei andere
videos und wenn ihr schon abonnent seid
könnt ihr auf die glocken klicken dann
willkommen die benachrichtigungen
[Musik]